welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am of course Benjamin Dixon filling in
for David as we speak the confirmation
hearings into Brett Kavanaugh Donald
Trump's nominee for the Supreme Court
they are going on and from what we can
tell during this recording is that the
Democrats are protesting they are they
have a coordinated protest effort to
bring attention to the fact that there
are tens of thousands of documents that
the Republicans have are stopping from
coming out and these documents are
focused particularly during his time
Kevin knows time in the tranio the Bush
administration during the Iraq war
42,000 documents were dropped on
Democrats and last night the night
before the hearing today and so
Democrats are protesting will give you a
full breakdown of that in tone
tomorrow's episode but just to be clear
about number one who Cavanaugh is he is
an extremist he is being appointed to
the Supreme Court in order to overturn
Roe vs. Wade he is also being appointed
to the Supreme Court because of how he
views presidential power and how he is
willing to extend a more power to
president Trump particularly in this
Muller probe and the investigation
surrounding it and so he is a dangerous
figure who really is probably going to
be confirmed if Democrats cannot
convince someone like Susan Collins to
vote against him and that's the problem
that's the problem here Democrats have
found themselves in a position where
there's not really much that they can do
except to try to convince someone on the
other side of the aisle that they should
withhold their vote and this puts us in
a really bad position for almost the
next 30 years however old you know
however loaned Kavanagh will would serve
on the bench I mean almost for the rest
of our lives and this is why I really
look at anyone who thinks especially
people
the left who thinks that the right move
or it wasn't so bad that Trump got into
office people who are literally using
their platforms very large platforms
very well-known platforms by some other
people that I won't mention on David's
show but if you want to know the details
come to my show and I'll call out names
people with these large platforms on
YouTube who are saying that this is not
a big deal that we can you know that
Trump is going to start the revolution
um you know he's gonna force everyone to
become more progressive that's not
happening what's happening is that
Donald Trump is making appointments up
and down the judiciary that are going to
outlast our lifetimes and because of
that the Democrats when they get back
into power they really only have one
route they only have one option and that
is to play hardball they're going to
need to do something like to stack the
courts just to offset what Donald Trump
is doing in this period that is so
extreme that many other Republican
administrations would not have done it
in terms of their political appointments
so here we are I mean and again hang on
I want to make sure that you're not that
you don't misconstrue what I'm saying
that that any other previous Republican
administration was more moderate because
they were not it's simply that we're in
such a hyper partisan time right now
that a person in a character like Donald
Trump knows how much he can exploit it
without any ramifications of course I
think Republicans would have tried to
put someone who would overturn Roe vs.
Wade
on the bench except for the type of
backlash that they would have been
presented with not only from Democrats
but from the public in general but we've
come to a point in politics today that
that's no longer the case and because
we're in this hyper partisan era where
Republicans are running up the
scoreboard with extremist conservative
extremists who are trying to rewrite
American history who are trying to undo
the last 100 years they want to in undo
the entire 20th century so that they can
take us back to the Gilded Age which
economically speaking we are literally
already there in terms of levels of
inequality but I digress
the point is this is that if there's no
one to hold these people accountable
they will continue to appoint more and
more extreme conservatives to the bench
and to get them elected into power and
it makes absolutely no sense for
Democrats going forward to try to
triangulate and play nice with these
people because they are playing for
keeps I say this all the time and I'm
going to keep saying it you cannot be
reasonable with unreasonable people you
cannot be reasonable and unreasonable
times and we are immersed most certainly
dealing with a very disingenuous group
of Republicans who have absolutely no
intention in engaging in good faith who
will literally get on television and
look you dead in the eye and lie to you
who will rewrite history for their
political ends for their political gain
and we have Democrats who are still
thinking that we can negotiate with them
you don't negotiate with political
terrorists you don't negotiate with
people who would just as soon whether
die than to let Obamacare stand for
example and the reason I bring that up
is because as we all well know Obamacare
is a conservative idea it comes from the
Heritage Foundation first tested in in
in Massachusetts by Mitt Romney and I
bring that up in context of this to
demonstrate just how disingenuous
conservatives are if they were true
about they what they really believed
that they would have gotten behind
President Obama because he got behind
one of their ideas but that is not what
they are here for they are here for
nothing else but pure political
partisanship and sportsmanship this is a
game to them they want nothing else but
to maintain political power at all cost
and if that means betraying what they
believe they have no problem with it
whatsoever you cannot be reasonable with
unreasonable people and unreasonable
times and so Democrats once they get
back in power are going to have to play
hardball and anyone who is talking about
you know working with
and reaching across the aisles
absolutely should not be running should
not get past a primary because we don't
have time for that when we're dealing
with people who would just assume see
the world burn than to give give anyone
who's not conservative because I don't
want to mistake and say just Democrats
but they would rather see the world burn
just give anyone who's not a
conservative and opportunity to do
something constructive
that is how unreasonable these times are
and if we don't understand the score we
are always going to be losing